jean bien sûr je pose une question sur
les empreintes et la base bon ce que je
dis c'est là c'est la modification que
nous sommes prêts à porter c'est que il
faut distinguer la prise des empreintes
papier qui existe depuis 1955 que nous
n'allons pas remettre en cause ce en
quoi nous mettrions en cause la sécurité
des français au regard du risque
terroriste notamment
c'est ce n'est pas la prise de
l'empreinte qui sera volontaire ou pas
c'est le transfèrement dans la base
numérisées de cette empreinte de manière
à ce que l'empreinte ne figure pas dans
la base centrale si les personnes ne le
souhaite pas c'est une garantie
considérable que nous apportons la donc
si les personnes ne veulent pas
bénéficier du service que nous apportons
elles peuvent non pas s'opposer à la
prise de leur empreinte puisque ça ça
existe depuis 1955 et que c'est
fondamental en matière de lutte contre
le crime
mais elles pourront s'opposer au
transfert au conte à la conservation
numérique de cette empreinte dans la
base voilà et ensuite vous posez elle
sera un peu plus difficile à
reconstituer mais nous pouvons quand
même allé dans son dossier papier et
nous ne perdrons pas en sécurité
nous perdons en simplification mais ça
bien entendu la personne si vous voulez
oui mais c'est bien ça le sujet
l'équilibré auquel nous sommes arrivés
c'est à dire que la personne qui ne veut
pas que son empreinte soit versée dans
la base ne perdra pas en sécurité
mais elle perdra en simplification et
rapidité au moment du renouvellement de
la carte
alors monsieur mini c'est sa jambière